- All-Star Sunday
In the city of Atlanta,
where the best in the game will
gather.
Taco Bell Skills Challenge
begins the competitions here
on All-Star Sunday.
And there
it is for
Domantas Sabonis.
- Wow.
- Vuce had too much arc.
- Mountain Dew Three-Point Contest
Championship.
- This is a one-man race, D-Wade.
- Here we go.
- Oh!
- Ah, this is too easy,
man.
- He's gonna make ‘em think!
- UTAHHH!
- He's making ‘em think about it.
He's got 27.
- OK, 27.
- Steph Curry gotta work here.
- He's gotta work here.
- Oh, he gotta make this.
this.
- Ohhh!
- He got ‘em.
- Oh, that is how you win.
- Stephen Curry!
- Cassius Stanley!
- Go get that, young fella! I told
you, he didn't come to play!
- Oh.
Oh! I like it!
- Your AT&T Slam Dunk champion,
Anfernee Simons!
- Now it's time for the 70th NBA
All-Star Game.
- It's Team LeBron
going against Team Durant.
Tatum sets it up for Zion
Williamson.
Three-pointer for Giannis
Antetokounmpo.
LeBron gets downcourt in a hurry.
Oh, my.
- You see what you started, Reggie?
- Anything you can do,
I can do better, Mr. Lillard
- You see Team LeBron dominating Team
Durant.
Lillard for three, yes!
- Dame Time, baby.
- Two on one, finished
by Donovan Mitchell.
And Irving on the drive,
and he stuffs.
- What's Lillard thinking about here?
- Dame Time, baby.
- He’s saying that's it!
- He's thinking about Dame Time!
- The three from Lillard, and it's all
over.
170-150
Team LeBron with
the victory.